ازمه نقص الطاقه وارتفاع الاسعار لا تزالت
مخيم وعلى الدول الاوروبيه مع دخول فصل
الشتاء قارس دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي
محاوله للحد من موجه ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
تدرس مقترحا لوضع سقف لاسعار الغاز دون
المستويات المقترحه وفق وثيقه اطلعت عليها
وكاله رويترز ازمه الطاقه وضدت جهود
الوزراء الاوروبيين في امكانيه التوصل الى
اتفاق مرضي حول اسعار الطاقه والرد على
مخاوف ما اذا كان الامر سيخفف من الازمه
في القاره او يفاقمها
جمهوريه التشيك وضعت مسوده اتفاق جديد في
محاوله لكسر الجنود يتضمن تفعيل حد اقصى
اذا تجاوزت اسعار عقد مركز تسهيل تداول
الغاز الهولندي تي اف في تعاقدات اقرب شهر
188 يورو للميجاوات ساعه لمده ثلاثه ايام
المقترح اقل بكثير من مست 200 2075 يورو
لكل ميغاوات ساعه الذي اقترحه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه والذي لم يلاقي ترحيبا من دول
اوروبيه وسط تاكيدات على ان الحد الاقصى
يجب ان يكون دون المئه يورو لمواجهه
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز الذي تسبب في ارتفاع
فواتير المستهلكين ومع استمرار روسيا في
قطع غالبيه الغاز الذي كانت ترسله الى
اوروبا وتسببها في ارتفاع الاسعار ودفع
التضخم الى مستويات قياسيه تسعى دول
اوروبيه الى استخدام وسائل التدفئه
التقليديه القديمه والفحم فيما شرعت
المانيا في استخدام اول وحده عامه لانتاج
الغاز الطبيعي المسال